Le 1er septembre 1729,
un gréement descend la Garonne jusqu'à son embouchure.
Une fois au large, il prend la direction des côtes africaines.
Bordeaux vient de basculer dans l'ère de la traite.
- Le premier bateau qui marque le début
de la traite négrière bordelaise
de manière constante s'appelle l'Union.
Voilà, donc il est parti en septembre 1729 de Bordeaux.
Tout ce qui avait précédé, c'est de l'ordre des prémices.
Si l'Union ouvre la voie aux négriers bordelais,
leur négoce n'explose que dans la seconde moitié du 18ème siècle.
Au total, ce seront 130 000 esclaves
qui seront vendus par des armateurs girondins.
Toutefois, Bordeaux ne dépassera jamais Nantes, premier port négrier français.
- La traite négrière, ça sera, si j'ose dire
le second choix des négociants bordelais
parce que Bordeaux a l'immense avantage d'avoir
un arrière pays très riche.
- Et ils ont le vin donc les traites,
pour eux, c'est relativement accessoire.
Et c'est sous Louis XV,
c'est la royauté qui insiste pour que les Bordelais
se mettent à faire la traite des Noirs.
Et les Bordelais reçoivent des subventions
jusqu'à la Révolution française
ils touchent de l'argent.
Tant de livres par tonneau de jauge,
tant de livres par noirs débarqués aux Antilles.
Et ça, évidemment, ça a été un stimulant extrêmement important.
Ce commerce triangulaire entre Bordeaux,
l'Afrique et les Antilles est encouragé par l'Etat,
car il permet le développement de comptoirs
et de plantations dans les îles des Caraïbes.
Les expéditions durent souvent plus d'une année
et ne se font jamais cales vides.
Dans ces cales, le vin est toujours là,
qui côtoie d'autres marchandises.
- L'état major du navire ne part jamais sans vin.
Le contrat qui est signé entre le capitaine et l'armateur,
il est bien stipulé que le capitaine ne partira
que s'il a des barils de bon vin à disposition dans le navire.
En même temps que du vin,
on embarque aussi de la pacotille et des armes
destinées à être échangées en Afrique contre des esclaves.
Ces esclaves sont chargés comme de vulgaires marchandises dans les cales,
où ils ne peuvent même pas se tenir debout.
Une fois parvenue à Saint-Domingue ou en Martinique,
la cargaison humaine est remplacée par du café,
du chocolat, de l'indigo.
Les négociants bordelais rentabilisent le voyage
et tiennent une comptabilité sordide dans leur carnet de bord.
Le Musée d'Aquitaine possède plusieurs de ses carnets.
Ils témoignent de la vie à bord
et d'un quotidien fait d'horreurs et d'inhumanité.
Beau, clair de lune.
Le temps. Toujours le même à onze heures trois quarts,
je fis monter une assez jolie négresse dans ma chambre.
Je passais deux heures avec elle et l'exploiter deux fois.
C'était la première femme que j'avais vu depuis mon départ de France.
On tenait aussi une comptabilité parallèle, celle
des esclaves morts durant la traversée.
Nous voyons apparaître clairement également une comptabilité macabre
avec un symbole apparaissant dans les marges
qui ne sont autres que des croix,
et à chacune des croix qui apparaissent
en face est mentionné à chaque fois de manière inéluctable
le décès d'un esclave et principalement du scorbut
qui montre, au delà des conditions de traversée tout à fait terribles,
que les maladies, les mauvaises conditions de vie
étaient bien entendu source d'une très forte mortalité
à l'intérieur de ces navires négriers.
Lors de ces traversées, la mortalité pouvait toucher 30% des hommes embarqués.
Mais en vendant les survivants à bon prix,
les marchands d'esclaves faisaient des gains substantiels.
Ce qui explique que des familles
bordelaises et gagner beaucoup, beaucoup d'argent.
Parmi ces familles, les Néracais.
Leur patronyme a traversé les siècles.
Un deuxième grand cru classé continue de porter leur nom.
C'est grâce au commerce colonial et négrier
que les Nérac des protestants régnèrent sur le port
de Bordeaux
dans la seconde moitié du 18ème siècle est devenu le premier port d'Europe.
Bordeaux devient l'entrepôt du commerce de
redistribution des produits coloniaux vers l'Europe.
Générac possède une flotte de huit navires, dont trois négriers.
On estime leur fortune à 2 millions de livres.
Pour vous donner un ordre de comparaison
à matelot qui la traite, ou en tout cas un matelot de marine
marchande
gagne 25 livres par mois
en moyenne 2 millions, une fortune et un salaire mensuel de 25 néos.
C'était l'homme le plus riche de Bordeaux.
Avec cet argent.
Nérac bâtissent en 1775 un imposant hôtel particulier.
l'Hôtel Nérac se trouve au centre de Bordeaux
et contribuent
jusqu'à nos jours
à la splendeur de la capitale girondine.
Les Nérac ont engagé l'architecte bordelais le plus coté.
Victor Louis, à qui l'on doit le Grand Théâtre.
Un génie que s'arrachent alors les fortunes locales.
Bordeaux. A cette époque vit sans doute ses heures les plus prospères.
Les richesses tirées du commerce maritime et de
la traite négrière rejaillissent sur le vignoble.
En 1777, les Nérac rachètent un domaine à Barsac, dans la région de Sauternes.
On y produit toujours un blanc liquoreux classé.
Si les Nérac investissent au sud de Bordeaux et non dans le Médoc, c'est qu'ils veulent édifier leur château le long de la voie menant
de Bordeaux à Toulouse, axe important du commerce, afin que leurs demeures soient vues du plus grand nombre et pour la rendre plus attrayante.
Ils vont cette fois faire appel à l'architecte André Mollier,
un collaborateur de Victor Louis Le Château Nérac Ainées.
Dans un cadre de vie luxueux, certes, mais discret, en plein accord avec leur
austérité protestante, Générac aime recevoir, tisser des relations, entretenir leur position de grands notables.
Des notables qui se rêvent aristocrate et qui vont jouer de
l'or entre gens pour demander au roi des lettres de noblesse.
Demande refusée.
Les Archives départementales de Gironde conservent la réponse royale.
Les motivations de celle ci peuvent surprendre.
En effet, le refus n'est pas motivé par l'ignominie
de la traite négrière, mais par la religion Générac.
Ne sont ils pas réformés?
Voilà la réponse du pouvoir royal à la
demande de Nallons Wilson, des frères Nérac.
C'est un refus, un refus, et la raison d'ailleurs est indiquée.
Cependant, monsieur, je ne saurais donner mon suffrage au sieur Nérac.
C'est sans doute à regret que je le refuse.
Mais la RPR, religion prétendue réformée ils font profession me parait, dans
les principes constitutionnels, former un obstacle puissant au succès de leurs désirs.
Les frères Anurag sont protestants.
Ils ne seront donc pas nombreux.
Les Nérac ne seront jamais nobles et les vents
abolitionnistes qui commencent à souffler vont balayer leurs fortunes.
Après la révolution, l'esclavage est aboli une première
fois, les Archives nationales conservent ce décret symbolique.
En 1794, la Convention nationale déclare que l'esclavage
des nègres dans toutes les colonies est aboli.
En conséquence, elle décrète que tous les hommes, sans distinction
de couleur, domiciliés dans les colonies sont citoyens français.
Bonaparte, pour favoriser les intérêts économiques des colonies,
va revenir en 1802 sur cette abolition.
Ce n'est qu'un demi siècle plus tard que l'esclavage
sera définitivement aboli par l'article 6 de la Constitution.
Une décennie plus tôt, en 1837, la famille Nérac avait revendu son domaine.